Schönen Nachmittag.
- Dir auch, danke.
Maya Graf entlässt
Bundesratskandidatin Viola Amherd
aus dem Hearing.
Sie wurde soeben von der Frauenlobby
in die Mangel genommen.
Ihrer Konkurrentin Heidi Z'graggen
steht das Hearing noch bevor.
Wir haben beschlossen,
dass wir dir auch Du sagen.
So herrschen die gleichen
Bedingungen. Ist das Okay? - Ja.
Bitte!
Auch Karin Keller Sutter
musste Rede und Antwort stehen.
Sie ist die dritte Frau
im Rennen um den Bundesratssitz.
Der einzige männliche Kandidat
ist Hans Wicki.
Zur Auswahl
stehen drei Frauen und nur ein Mann.
Zufall?
Oder Bravourstück der Frauenlobby?
Auf der Suche nach einer Antwort
hefte ich mich an Maya Grafs Fersen.
Sie gehört zu den Frontfrauen
der Bundeshausfeministinnen.
Mein erster Eindruck: die Frau
ist verdammt schnell unterwegs.
Man ist immer
schneller als der Lift
und hat dazu noch etwas
für seine Fitness gemacht.
Ich laufe immer so schnell.
Ich musste schon als Kind ca. 1 Std.
in die Primarschule laufen.
Dann lernt man schnell laufen.
Also nie zu spät gekommen?
Nein, vielleicht zu spät nach Hause.
Kommen Sie mit? - Ja.
Sie sind parat?
Was machen Sie jetzt?
- Mich etwas ...
Kraft tanken. Muss man das für heute?
Es ist eher etwas lockern.
Brauchen Sie Lockerheit?
Die braucht man jeden Tag und immer.
In der Frauenpolitik auch?
Sicher. Ich denke, gerade dort ist
Verbissenheit die falsche Antwort.
Es braucht
Hartnäckigkeit und Lockerheit.
Das ist eine schwierige Kombination.
* Gelassene Klänge *
Etwas ernst.
Sie wissen,
wir können es kurz machen.
Einmal mehr hat es keine Frau
in den Bundesrat geschafft.
Herr Cassis wurde gewählt.
Bereits vor einem Jahr
machen die Co-Präsidentinnen
Maya Graf und Kathrin Bertschy
an der Präsidentinnenkonferenz des
Frauendachverbandes Alliance F mobil.
Mehr Frauen in den Bundesrat!
Bislang hatte die Schweiz 110 Bundes-
räte und nur sieben Bundesrätinnen.
Eine magere Bilanz!
Alle raus, bitte!
Frau Bundesrätin wartet auf uns ...
... auf der Treppe,
vor den drei Eidgenossen.
Kommt, liebe Frauen,
stellt euch hin! Kommt, kommt!
Schnell! Depechez-vous!
Und jetzt reihenweise
hinter die Bundesrätin!
Also so neben mich.
Beim Fototermin
mit Bundesrätin Simonetta Sommaruga:
Alles Frauen -
aber auch nur fürs Bild.
Das Bundeshaus ist ein Männerladen.
Maya Graf und ihre Mitstreiterinnen
wollen das nachhaltig ändern.
Wir haben sicher nicht
qualitativ die besten Leute,
weil es immer nur Männer sind.
Die Talente sind nicht so einseitig
auf die Menschheit verteilt worden.
Für mich ist es
ein Gerechtigkeitsanliegen.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass die Frauen weniger Wert sind.
Frauenpower und Frauensolidarität.
Diese Parolen höre ich während
meiner Dreharbeiten immer wieder.
Existiert so was wie ein Wir-Gefühl
unter Spitzenpolitikerinnen?
Ich begleite Maya Graf
in ihrem Bundeshausalltag.
Frauenpolitik - d.h. natürlich nicht
nur Bundesratskandidaten befragen.
Es ist ein hartes Stück Arbeit.
Maya Graf
feilt gerade an ihrem Vorstoss
zur Erhaltung des Gosteli-Archivs;
einer Sammlung
von wertvollen Dokumenten
zur Geschichte der Frauenbewegung.
Der Stiftung geht das Geld aus.
Während die politische Geschichte
der Männer
in staatlichen Archiven untergebracht
ist, ist jene der Frauen Privatsache.
Maya Graf will das Archiv zusammen
mit fünf Ratskolleginnen retten.
Eine davon:
Susanne Leutenegger-Oberholzer.
Hast du es als Anzeigebild?
Schickst du es mir?
Du siehst aus wie ein Teenie.
Das ist Teenie. Schickst du mir das?
Hier, das erwähnte Bild auf Twitter.
Die beiden Nationalrätinnen
reissen sich für die gemeinsame Sache
zusammen. Es kriselt.
Wie ich im Gespräch mit Susanne
Leutenegger-Oberholzer erfahre.
Am Wochenende
sei sie für das gemeinsame Anliegen
allein unterwegs gewesen
und fühle sich von Ratskolleginnen
im Stich gelassen.
Ich war alleine vor der Postulantin.
- Ja, ja. Und, wie war es?
Ich habe mich aufgeregt,
dass ich alleine war.
Sie haben den Vorwurf sicher gehört,
weil Sie am Wochenende
nicht da waren?
Oder man
nicht vereint mitgegangen ist.
Es ist eine gewisse Enttäuschung da.
Nein, das habe ich nicht gehört.
Es passt eben nicht immer allen.
Wir alle sind während der Session
und auch am Wochenende
sehr beschäftigt.
Es hat jede ihre Meinung.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Gewisse machen seit Jahren,
seit Jahrzehnten
auf jeder Ebene Frauenpolitik.
Über eine solche Petitesse kann ich
mich nicht länger aufhalten.
Müssen Sie gehen?
- Ja.
Zufall oder nicht.
Bei der anschliessenden Besprechung
der Frauen
fehlt Susanne Leutenegger-Oberholzer.
Die restlichen Nationalrätinnen -
jede aus einer anderen Partei -
demonstrieren Einigkeit.
Gemeinsam wollen sie
eine Mehrheit schaffen.
Es ist ein Stück
Schweizer Geschichte.
Du sagst ja:
"Wer keine Vergangenheit hat ..."
Wer die Vergangenheit nicht
versteht, hat keine Zukunft.
Das war in ihrer Todesanzeige.
"Ohne Kenntnis der Geschichte
gibt es keine Zukunft."
Das sage ich,
einfach mit anderen Worten.
Aber ich sage das schon.
Ich beginne eigentlich,
bevor ich sage:
"Sehr geehrter Präsident" und so ...
Ist es übrigens Berset?
- Ja.
Barbara, sagst du diese Zahlen?
- So nicht.
Also nicht detailliert?
Jetzt sind wir bald an der Reihe.
Noch nicht.
- Doch, ich finde schon.
Sind Sie Feministin?
Ich bin eine liberale Kämpferin
für die Anliegen der Frau.
Und unsere Situation hier ist
eine so komfortable, gute Situation.
Auch wenn vielleicht die Jusos
einmal sehr kämpferisch
ihre Büstenhalter verbrennen,
kann ich das
mit mehr Gelassenheit angehen.
Das würden Sie nie machen?
Büstenhalter verbrennen
erinnert mich an die 70er-Jahre.
Ich würde das als Weg
zu wenig modern einstufen.
Jetzt muss ich etwas trinken.
Das vergisst man gerne,
wenn man immer unterwegs ist,
dass man auch trinken sollte,
v.a. wenn man nachher reden muss.
Ist jetzt nach der Besprechung
alles klar?
Ja, das kommt schon gut.
Um auch gute Signale ... also ...
(Frau) Maya!
- Ja.
Yeah!
Vielen Dank.
- Das ist ein tolles Resultat, was?
Der Nationalrat
hat die fünf gleichlautenden
Vorstösse der Frauen angenommen.
Sehr zur Freude der Interessen-
gemeinschaft der Gosteli-Stiftung.
Trotz allem: zwischen Maya Graf
und Susanne Leutenegger Oberholzer
herrscht immer noch dicke Luft.
Das spürt man.
Deshalb hake ich später
noch einmal nach.
Es gab ja einen kleinen Zickenkrieg
zwischen Ihnen
und Frau Leutenegger Oberholzer.
Stichwort: Frauensolidarität.
Gibt es die hier drin wirklich,
oder sind eben nicht die Frauen der
Partei oder sich selber am nächsten?
Ich muss fast lachen,
weil sie einen Zickenkrieg erwähnen.
Bei Männern würde man das Wort
gar nicht benutzen.
Da würde man sagen: "Sie haben
eine Auseinandersetzung geführt."
Okay, es war
eine Auseinandersetzung.
Das ist auch gleich die Antwort.
Selbstverständlich
sind sich die Frauen
nicht immer einig über ein Vorgehen.
Wenn sich Männer nicht einig sind,
ist das immer eine Stärke,
bei Frauen eine Schwäche.
Die Politik schafft die Spielregeln
unserer Gesellschaft.
Und ich frage mich:
Bin ich als Frau hier gut vertreten?
Schliesslich beträgt
der weibliche Anteil im Nationalrat
gerade mal 30 %, im Ständerat ist
der Anteil der Frauen noch tiefer.
Für eine Gleichstellung
bräuchte es eindeutig mehr Frauen
in Entscheidungsgremien.
In der Bundesrätinnen-Frage will Maya
Graf endlich Nägel mit Köpfen machen.
Aber wie? Das zeigt sie mir anhand
der für heute geplanten Aktion.
Bin gespannt,
ob schon Frauen hier sind.
Kameras hat es auch schon.
Das sieht tipptopp aus.
Hey, das ist ja grossartig!
Das ist grossartig.
Die Unterstützung steht schon parat.
Bist du bereit?
- Ja.
Es wird sehr schwierig.
- Ja?
Ja, es wird schwierig.
Es gab einen Wechsel in Kommission.
Die Rede ist
von der bevorstehenden Debatte.
Maya Graf
hat einen Vorstoss eingereicht.
Die Nationalrätin will eine angemes-
sene Vertretung beider Geschlechter
im Bundesrat per Verfassung regeln.
Darf ich etwas fragen,
bevor es losgeht?
Ich habe Sie noch nie gefragt,
warum Sie Feministin geworden sind.
Das haben Sie mich noch nie gefragt?
- Nein.
Ich bin es nicht geworden,
ich war das schon immer.
Wenn man als Frau geboren wird,
ist man eigentlich Feministin.
Nicht ganz alle.
Nein, aber für mich ist das so.
Feministin heisst ja:
Man ist eigentlich gleichwertig
und v.a. gleichberechtigt.
Und da ich ja schon älter bin
und eine Tochter habe,
die schon über 20 ist,
finde ich es eigentlich verrückt,
dass wir heute hier stehen
und immer noch dafür kämpfen müssen.
Wenn man denn eben die Macht oder
die Anteile an der Macht einfordert,
da geht es auch hart auf hart.
Es ist eben so:
Solange wir keine Quote
bzw. eine ergänzte Konkordanz haben,
die wir jetzt fordern,
so lange passiert nichts.
Besteht denn nicht die Gefahr,
dass man danach immer sagt:
Sie wurde aufgrund des Quotentickets
gewählt?
Ich werde lieber aufgrund
eines Quotentickets gewählt,
als gar nicht gewählt.
Bevor es in der Kommission
hart auf hart geht,
wird medienwirksam
die Werbetrommel gerührt:
mit Bundesrätinnen-Trikot
für eine gemischte Mannschaft.
Und los!
Einfach lachen, smile!
Danke!
Ins Sitzungszimmer
können Sie nicht rein.
Zutritt verboten.
Während die Kommission debattiert,
mache ich mir Gedanken
zum Stigma der Quotenfrau.
Sind denn von den Männern hier
nur die Besten drin? Eben.
Um es kurz zu machen:
Maya Grafs Vorstoss
wird von der Kommission abgelehnt -
auch von Frauen.
Sie haben dagegen gestimmt. Warum?
Frau sein
ist nicht das massgebende Kriterium.
Wir schauen eine Kandidatur
ganzheitlich an.
Ich weiss aus eigener Erfahrung,
ich bin ja schon
seit Jahren im Parlament ...
Frauen wie ich,
die bei der SVP politisieren,
haben überhaupt keine Unterstützung
von den Feministinnen.
Im Gegenteil, wir werden
oft noch schlecht gemacht.
Und es wird
das Haar in der Suppe gesucht.
Feminismus ist nicht wertneutral,
sondern richtet sich
v.a. an die Frauen,
die im linken Spektrum zu suchen
sind. Dort wird man gefördert.
Es ist eben wirklich
auch an den Frauen,
wenn sie dahinterstehen eine Frau zu
wählen und nicht einfach die Quote.
Ich denke, Frauensolidarität
ist leider nicht so funktionierend,
wie man es sich manchmal wünschte.
Das zeigt auch das Beispiel
bei Bundesratswahlen.
Sorry für die Verspätung.
- Kein Problem.
Ich habe ausgerechnet heute Morgen
meinen Hotelschlüssel verloren.
Frauen verschiedener Verbände
und Organisationen
haben sich im Bundeshaus eingefunden.
Der Ständerat stimmt heute über
Massnahmen zur Lohngleichheit ab.
Weil Frauen noch immer weniger
als Männer verdienen würden,
wollen sie mit ihrer Präsenz
Druck ausüben.
Und weil im Ständerat nicht bei allen
Abstimmungen veröffentlicht wird,
wer wie stimmt, nehmen die Frauen
die Parlamentarier ins Visier.
Mithilfe einer Sitzordnung.
Haben Sie das Gefühl,
die Ständeräte beeinflusst das?
Sie sehen die Frauen und denken:
"Okay, ich stimme anders."
Das ist natürlich
ein wenig die Hoffnung.
Dass sie sehen ...
- Tatsächlich?
Ja, dass sie sehen,
hier ist ein Interesse.
Das, was wir hier machen,
wird beobachtet.
Wird beurteilt.
So wie die Frauen
oben auf der Tribüne
wollen auch die Nationalrätinnen mit
ihrer Anwesenheit im Ständeratssaal
ein Zeichen setzen.
Wir dealen nicht mehr.
(Flüstert) Wir dealen nicht mehr.
Man muss es jetzt einfach machen.
Die Schweiz geht nicht unter.
Für mich ist es auch klar, dass
diese Vorlage und dieses Gesetz
ein Gesetz ist,
das es nicht braucht.
Die Wirtschaft
hat die Zeichen der Zeit
und das Potenzial von Frauen
längstens erkannt
und handelt auch entsprechend.
Wir stellen
viele Ungerechtigkeiten fest.
Lohnungleichheiten
gibt es innerhalb der Branchen.
Das wird
als gottgegeben angenommen.
Ist auch so zu akzeptieren.
Das ist ein Teil
unserer wirtschaftlichen Freiheit.
... dafür einen kurzen Schritt
zurückmachen,
denn in der ganzen Debatte
scheint es bisher
als sakrosankte Prämisse zu gelten,
dass eine Lohndifferenz,
die wir nicht erklären können,
automatisch diskriminierend sei.
Das ist ein logischer Fehlschluss.
Es geht um Frauenanliegen.
Es stimmen aber
hauptsächlich Männer ab.
39 um genau zu sein.
Frauen gibt es im Ständerat
gerade mal sieben.
Das Geschäft wird zurück
in die Kommission geschickt.
In 100 Jahren schaffen wir es nicht,
dass irgendwann etwas vorwärts geht.
Das ist eine Katastrophe!
Das ist übel!
Ich finde die Argumente,
die genannt werden furchtbar.
Immer wieder verzögern.
Es ist schlimm.
Super enttäuscht, super enttäuscht!
Es war so hinterhältig,
der Rückweisungsantrag.
Es ist einfach wirklich nur feige.
Anstatt hinstehen und sagen:
"Ja, es ist uns egal."
Erneut ein Dämpfer, doch so schnell
geben die Frauen nicht auf.
Die Notizen werden eingesammelt.
Die Retourkutsche
kommt postwendend per Tweet.
Die Mitteilung:
"Diese Männer blockieren Massnahmen
zur Lohngleichheit."
Die Herren Ständeräte am Pranger.
Haben Sie das gesehen?
Sie sind hier auf der Liste:
Nicht mein Ständerat.
- Nein, das sehe ich zum ersten Mal.
Beeindruckt Sie das nicht?
Kein schlechtes Gewissen?
Es gehört zur Politik,
dass man für seine Meinung kämpft.
Ich finde es etwas populistisch.
Und sicher
einer Frauenpolitik unwürdig.
Deswegen habe ich
kein schlechtes Gewissen.
Wieso haben Sie denn so gestimmt?
Jede Frau,
die heute vor Gericht geht,
weil sie nicht gleich bezahlt ist,
bekommt recht.
Diese Mittel gibt es.
Muss man zuerst vor Gericht gehen?
- Rechte müssen erkämpft werden.
Rechte bekommt man nicht geschenkt.
Noch einen schönen Tag.
- Danke.
Haben Sie die Liste schon gesehen?
Nein, ich habe sie nicht gesehen.
Die Aussage von oben
teile ich vollständig.
Aber warum ich da drauf bin,
weiss ich nicht.
Weil Sie dagegen gestimmt haben.
- Ich habe nicht dagegen gestimmt.
Aber sie haben es zurückgeschickt.
Ja, sonst wäre es gescheitert.
Gleichstellungswitz? Keine Ahnung.
Ständerat Andrea Caroni erzählt -
passend zum Thema, wie er findet -
einen Frauenwitz.
Vor der Kamera will er diesen
aber nicht wiederholen.
Ich stelle fest, Sie finden
den überhaupt nicht lustig.
Ich finde auch
nicht jeden Männerwitz lustig.
Sehen Sie sich auf der Liste?
Wenn es gut recherchiert ist
bin ich darauf.
Es sassen sehr viele Frauen
auf der Zuschauertribüne,
Nationalrätinnen bei euch im Saal.
Haben Sie das wahrgenommen?
Das habe ich schon wahrgenommen.
Wir erleben ja alle Arten
von Interessenvertretungen.
Von den Politikerinnen
kenne ich viele.
Ich war früher im Nationalrat.
Ich freue mich immer,
wenn ich sie sehe.
Im Ständerat fällt auf,
dass es sehr wenig Frauen hat.
Es hat aber bei Ihnen nichts bewirkt.
Sie gehen hoffentlich
nicht davon aus,
dass ich immer so stimme wie
die drei Leute hinter mir denken.
Ich überlege mir dass vertieft.
Verstaubter Macho oder
feminismusfreundlicher Reformer?
Eine Sache des politischen Lagers?
Oder eine Generationenfrage?
Raphael Comte, FDP-Ständerat
aus Neuchatel. Und: Feminist.
Ähnlich wie Maya Graf
hat auch er einen Vorstoss zur
Frauenquote im Bundesrat eingereicht.
Allerdings im Ständerat.
Im Gegensatz zu Maya Graf
hat Raphael Comte gepunktet.
Ich sollte meine Brille anziehen.
Warum haben Sie als Mann
sich dafür eingesetzt?
Für mich ist die Gleichheit
zwischen Männern und Frauen
keine Frauenfrage.
Das betrifft die ganze Gesellschaft.
Als Mann fühle ich mich
in dieser Frage auch betroffen.
Ich denke, es gibt auch langsam
eine Änderung der Mentalität.
Das kommt.
Ist es nicht frustrierend,
wenn ihr Frauen immer kämpft,
dann kommt ein junger Mann
und schon klappt es?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Wir werden hier nur mehrheitsfähig,
wenn wir uns quasi
von der links-grünen Ecke
Richtung bürgerlich bewegen.
Und v.a., wenn Männer und Frauen
zusammen diese Themen behandeln.
Anscheinend
braucht es beide Geschlechter.
Knapp ein halbes Jahr später
komme ich wieder ins Bundeshaus.
Der Ständerat
stimmte im zweiten Anlauf
Massnahmen zur Lohngleichheit zu.
Auch der Nationalrat
hat die Vorlage angenommen,
allerdings
in einer abgeschwächten Form.
Den Bundeshausfeministinnen
ist in diesem Jahr
kein grosser Wurf gelungen,
aber die Summe macht's aus.
Die mediale Aufmerksamkeit.
Der permanente Druck,
auch von der Gesellschaft.
Die Parteien kommen
um die Frauenfrage nicht mehr herum.
Das zeigt auch die Wahl der
nominierten Bundesratskandidaten.
Doch wie viele Frauen sollen es denn
im Siebner-Gremium sein?
Salü, Hans!
- Schönes Wochenende. - Dir auch.
Angemessen vertreten heisst entweder
vier oder drei oder wechselnd.
Drei oder vier?
- Drei ist sicher das Minimum.
Es ist mir egal, wie viele Frauen
im Bundesrat sein sollten,
auch wie viele Männer.
Es sollen die Besten gewählt werden.
Ich muss wirklich gehen.
Ich muss in ein Livegespräch.
Nur kurz. Wie viele Frauen
sollten im Bundesrat sein?
Ich habe wirklich keine Zeit.
November 2018:
die Szene wiederholt sich.
Noch nach hinten.
Fototermin der Frauen
mit der Bundesrätin,
diesmal mit Doris Leuthard.
Was den Fototermin
vom kommenden Jahr anbelangt:
Für Nachschub ist bereits gesorgt.
So viele Kameras
hatten wir noch nie.
Jochi, du musst auf die Seite,
wir wollen jetzt keine Männer.
Heute wollen wir keine Männer.
- Damit habe ich keine Mühe!
Sicher? Gut.